get out of here i'll see you later
all right you know where to find us
it is weird staring at you for that long
Welcomeback everyone
we have a bunch of spider man
no way home deleted scenes to break down alternate
ending with tobey maguire andrew garfield so if
you're brand new to the channel we are doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite easter egg from the movie on the video
but in the new deleted scenes they just released
you can see that when tom holland's mcu spider-man
is saying his last goodbye to toby maguire
and andrew garfield spider-man andrew garfield
clearly says you know where to find us before
doctor strange's second spell then sends them
back to all their original universes meaning that
the writers were trying to set up another future
spider-verse crossover with tobey maguire and
andrew garfield make it a little more discreet
like yes we are planning on bringing them back
because he will remember them and he'll know where
to find them for those of you that want to see
them come back in future movies and i think that's
pretty much everybody everybody would like to see
tope maguire and andrew garfield come back again
there has been some discussion about that
recently that i'll address later in the video
but there's a lot to unpack in this scene when he
says you know where to find us it also means the
writers intended for both toby maguire and andrew
garfield to remember tom hall and spider-man after
dr strange's second spell for those of you
that still have questions about what the true
effects of the memory spell are like did it white
peter parker from all digital records databases
will iron man's edith ai remember peter
parker i'll address that in a second too
but clearly the writers also intended for
tom holland's mcu spider man do call on toby
mcguire and andrew garfield again in their
own universes like you know where to find
us literally in the multiverse wink wink you
know where our specific universes are located
meaning that mcu spider-man is going to use the
multiverse again just in general obviously it
also supports the idea that tobey maguire andrew
garfield will also come back at some point in a
future movie why would he need to remember where
to find them if they weren't going to come back
but i think part of the reason for that specific
alternate ending was to also help set up the venom
post-credit scene too and what was going on with
the venom character just in general with all these
multiverse twists venom being teleported to the
mcu because of the symbiote's hive memories that
extended across the multiverse and if you're
still confused about that if the first spell
only brought people to the main mcu universe
who already knew a version of peter parker was
a version of spider-man then when did tom hardy's
venom learn peter parker was spider-man because he
wasn't seeing the broadcast identifying him as
spider-man until he had been brought to the mcu
it's all because of the symbiote's hive
memories so tom hardy's version of the
venom symbiote had been cueing up memories from
across the multiverse to give him a big tutorial
in their hive knowledge and experiences
like let me give you a glimpse of this
and when that happened the symbiote was accessing
the memories of many different venoms from across
the multiverse one of them being topher grace's
venom symbiote in tobey maguire's universe and his
venom had learned that spider-man was peter parker
so that's the justification that they use for the
spell bringing venom to the mcu in the second
spell sending him back to the venom universe
but he did leave a piece of the symbiote behind so
yes they are setting up an mcu symbiote saga with
tom hall and spider-man pretty clearly they'll
probably continue with that story thread during
spider-man 4 even if that movie isn't just
about him getting the symbiote but in that
deleted scene where they clarify everyone is going
to remember everyone else or at least some of them
will remember and tom hall and spider-man will
use the multiverse again it also just helps set
up future tom holland crossover with tom hardy's
venom if mcu spider-man is going to continue to
use the multiverse because based on that venom
post credit scene as we saw it in theaters
you could you could just do an mcu symbiote saga
without having to bring back tom hardy's venom
but that would be way less fun like why would you
go through the trouble of bringing tom hardy to
the mcu and then only having there for a couple
seconds and then never ever bring him back again
so this alternate ending deleted scene just gives
them some more options for how all those future
crossovers with all those different versions of
spider-man and venom go down and it gives you
an idea for the way that marvel and sony were
thinking about the future of spider-man movies
and crossovers future of toggy mcguire andrew
garfield venom and to answer the question about
edith remembering spider-man or peter parker
the writer said they didn't spend a ton of time
trying to figure that out only that they assumed
that the power of the magic twist would be broad
enough that the spell would just take care of any
inconsistencies or plot holes but they also said
that when it came time to make spider-man 4 that
the writers of that movie would just interpret
the spell's effects however they wanted to for the
purposes of that story so there will be a couple
plot holes probably when they make spider-man 4.
i'm sure in like three or four years when they
make that movie there'll be hundreds of youtube
videos about these but the writers also explained
that they developed alternate post-credit scenes
for both toby mcguire and andrew garfield and
originally it would have been more than just
the venom scene in the doctor strange 2 trailer
their post-credit scenes would have just
shown what happened to both of them after dr
strange's second spell sent them back to each
of their universes like andrew garfield would
have been more inspired to become the friendly
neighborhood spider-man that his gwen stacy wanted
him to become he wasn't going to be as dark
or rageful he also kind of thought of himself
as the lame spider-man that was meant to be a
meta joke about his amazing spider-man movies
like each of the different versions of spider-man
kind of made fun of themselves a little bit
i'm lame compare like i fought a russian guy
in a like a rhinoceros machine andrew garfield
kind of thought of himself as the lame spider-man
because he didn't have any big avengers crossovers
and toby mcguire has always been thought of as
the fan favorite spider-man to be fair they did
make fun of tom hall and spider-man 2 when he was
trying to hype up his avengers crossovers i was in
the avengers the avengers yeah that's great thank
you what is that well you don't have the avengers
is that a bad are you in a band but when toby
maguire spider-man would have gone back to his
universe his post-credit scene would have just
shown him going back to his family and i don't
think that they ever planned on bringing kirsten
dunst back or showing a version of their child
at least according to kirsten dunst but toby
maguire spider-man had implied when he was talking
to andrew garfield spider-man that he eventually
was able to start a family with his version of mj
telling him that it was possible to have a
family and be spider-man because that was
andrew garfield's whole thing in the movies like
i just don't think that it's in the cards for us
to have normal lives because we're spider-man but
i think they could pay off that toby mcguire twist
in some future movie with a version of mayday
parker who is a version of his daughter who gets
his spider-man powers in the comics and becomes
a version of spider-woman when she gets older
i wouldn't give up it took a while but we made it
work yeah yeah me and mj and for those of you that
want them to make toby mcguire spider-man for an
amazing spider-man 3 toby mcguire actually said he
specifically told the writers not to get too far
into his timeline after the events of spider-man 3
because presumably they'll cover that backstory
in some future movie when he comes back again
i did a video a couple of years ago about
the plot of tobey maguire's spider-man 4
because all the storyboards leaked out sam raimi
had already finished the script they only canceled
the movie like right before they were getting
ready to roll camera and then they rebooted it
with the amazing spider-man andrew garfield
movies obviously revisiting you know what
what was part of my history and getting a chance
to like come together and a way to revisit and
just just to get to get back into that and i don't
want to say like close the chapter but revisit and
have certain resolutions um and and just join in
this like loving creative spirit the main villains
of toby maguire spider-man 4 would have been a
version of vulture played by john malkovich in
a version of mysterio played by wait for it
bruce campbell their backstories would have
been way different from what we saw in the mcu but
as we saw in spider-man homecoming spider-man far
from home they did bring back elements of those
characters and stories andrew garfield is also
really open to coming back as spider-man this
is what he said about that recently could you
would you do it again would you put the suit on if
given the opportunity you know never say never i
mean it's such it's it's a character that's always
gonna be so meaningful to me and so beautiful to
me and again it comes back to service you know i
think if there's a way because that's what that's
what that character is all about he's all about
serving the greater good and serving his fellow
fellow people his fellow you know serving
humanity and all life you know so if there's a way
for me to continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels
like it's of service to an audience of service to
the themes of you know the themes that stan lee
kind of uh you know injected that character
with i'm open of course i'm very very open
let me know in the comments though where
do you want to see toby maguire and andrew
garfield come back in future movies because
of what they did with spider man no way home
with the multiverse and with doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness with all the x-men coming
from the fox marvel movies really anything
is possible like there are no limits anymore
but congratulations to thorin woods you're
the giveaway winner for my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my new marvel moon knight
episode 1 trailer video in easter eggs and click
here for more spider man no way home deleted
scenes with toby mcguire and andrew garfield
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!